so you know how we're sitting down we're
watching how much U.S keeps giving to
Ukraine keeps giving to Ukraine and
Yellen just went there this week and she
announced that they're given an
additional 1.2 but 1.2010 but promising
ten right here's 1.2 but promising 10.
uh uh uh but promising 10 uh and you
know so people go oh my God how much
more I think the total right now is 114
billion dollars give or take okay do you
realize a couple things you know what's
the fastest way to stop this war if
you're so worried about 300 000 people
that have died with the number that you
give us 200 000 on the Russians and a
hundred thousand on Ukraine's and you
know what's the fastest way to finish
the war do you know what's the fastest
way to finish the war stop giving money
yeah do you realize that if you really
don't want war
stop giving money and set up the meeting
how come you haven't done that it's as
if America wants this war to continue so
when a Tulsi gabbard or some of these
guys get up and they talk about the
military
industrial complex you keep funding this
there's a reason why millions of people
resonate with what Tulsi gabbard and
others have to say maybe you do want to
war maybe this is a business model maybe
there is a benefit of us doing this to
continue this model that we're going
with all these wars because if America
truly wants no war right now you can
stop the money you can stop sending
weapons and if you do that Ukraine has
no choice to say let's talk let's figure
something out right now watch this
if you can pull up one of the things
that we've been sending to uh uh to uh
uh Ukraine is these Javelin missile
launchers okay a couple stats I want you
to see with this year if you can go back
to the first one go all the way to the
first one go one more there's one other
picture I sent you uh uh which is the
budget that we have okay zoom in on this
picture here take a look at this this is
our budget in 2021 versus other
military's budget that we have us 801 in
2021 look at China look at India you
could look at UK look at everyone else
we have a massive military budget that
we have a big chunk of this is financing
the 800 military bases that we have okay
trying to solve other people's problems
but the one thing we've given to to to
Ukraine a lot is 8 500 javelins to
Ukraine that's what US has committed if
you want to Google what a javelin is and
what it looks like military Ukraine so
people can see it 8 500 of them that's
been given to Ukraine there's a reason
why Ukraine is doing so well against
Russia because we this is not a war with
Ukraine against Russia this is a war of
U.S versus Russia okay period it's
public it's not even something we're
hiding we've given 8 500 of those to
Ukraine so what's the big deal
you know somebody may say what's that
what's the big deal about these javelins
were given to them Raytheon and Lockheed
Martin have both said that what's been
pledged from U.S in existing stock they
cannot do double the production and give
America back what they have till 2026
meaning everything we pretty much have
on stock of javelins we've pretty much
given to who to Ukraine okay these are
the numbers that we've given to them
just to support what they got going on
so now as you get closer with this
article that Wall Street Journal has
they show this data Tom you're gonna
love this year if you can show this on
the screen so our audience can see this
these are the numbers of contractors U.S
had in 1980 that we did business with
okay when I say contractors defense
company contractors okay that this is
where we got our weapons from so if you
look at this Vinnie 1981 there was 51
companies we did business with
every year or so one or two got bought
out we went from 51 to how many down to
five oh wow Lockheed Martin Boeing
Raytheon Northrop Grumman and General
Dynamics okay so one could look at this
and say well what's uh the big deal with
this show the next data if you go to
this one go two more go one more okay
from 1990 the number of contractors we
had tactical missile suppliers we had 13
that we bought from we only have three
today
fixed Wing aircraft suppliers we had
eight we got three today satellite
suppliers we had eight we got four today
Builders of surface ships we had eight
we have two today okay
these guys that keep buying up these
companies this is essentially being a
similar model to Banks how many banks do
we have in 1980s a ton of them how many
banks do we have today it's really only
five companies or cell phone companies
cell phone companies
everything is going to this and solid
everything I remember being on a call
with FTC when one of the bigger
Insurance technology companies that's a
behemoth if you're on the insurance
don't say the name if you're in the
insurance industry you know what I'm
talking about they were about to buy up
another competitor whom we were doing
business with both of them and they said
hey we would like to know XYZ they're
asking because they were pretty much
having a monopoly some of these guys
have so much control right now which the
problem becomes the following is America
you know how you raise money and all of
a sudden you buy 50 different companies
one by one by one by one by one you keep
buying other companies because you have
the money and then all of a sudden what
happens to you you wake up one day
you're like dude we got 400 companies
that we bought the last five years
we have no clue how to manage these
companies one by one they're going
bankrupt what the hell are we gonna do
you've stretched yourself so thin you
now have four or 500 military bases to
manage how do you do that the problem
today with America is if we keep giving
all these weapons to other people our
own supply is getting weaker and
Northrop and Raytheon are saying we
can't replace this for you till 2026
that's three years our own military is
getting weaker the more we try to
support everyone God forbid if the enemy
realizes that military and U.S
is experiencing this what does that tell
you that's an opportunity for what
attack to attack of course to realize
hey they're not as strong as we once
thought of course that's a real threat
and to say that we're getting this close
to a potential War
it's the closest we've been since you
know what do you want to call the Cuban
Missile Crisis I would say that's the
closest we've been where we could be a
part of this and we keep poking the
Bears so then the story leads to this
and then Tom I want to get your thoughts
on this first and then I'm going to come
to you next okay as our AI expert so
story comes out Putin will die in office
or with bullets in his back as despots
Futures predicted okay so this is a
story on page 13 War expert Nate Sibley
believes that Vladimir Putin will die
while serving as President of Russia and
that he could be assassinated simply
states that Putin's watched carefully as
other Soviet Union leaders try to
extricate themselves from authoritarian
regimes as they failed and that whatever
his future holds it is increasingly
unlikely to be a happy ending either of
old age or bulletin is back Putin has
previously survived several
assassination attempts with Oliver Stone
stating in 2012 interview that he had
heard of five attempts Putin himself
responded I do my job and the security
officers do theirs and they're still
performing quite successfully Putin's
Health has been a subject of much
speculation over the years with claims
that he has Parkinson's and travels with
a thyroid cancer doctor however he has
stated in the past that he has no plans
to retire and he has changed the
Constitution to allow him to rule
indefinitely make in modern day in
Russia a true autocracy so
with all this stuff going on in the
world and the uncertainties that we have
I I just think America may want to kind
of step back and take an inventory are
we as strong as we act like we are or we
have stretched ourselves so thin around
the world that this may have given an
opening for somebody to say you know
what if there's ever been a time to
attack maybe this is the time obviously
nobody wants to see War this next one
won't be pretty the goal is to prevent
this war Tom what are your thoughts on
this well first of all every Russian
leader dies in office because as much as
they say oh we have elections here yeah
right yeah your guys service until he
doesn't right that's the way that is and
to say well he'll either die in office
which is a certainty or he'll die in
office with assistance you know because
he's going to get shot I I don't think
there's really a story there but what
you're talking about is where is the
United States really on the world stage
and I agree with you if you just to
unload the cupboard and give all this
stuff to the Ukraine the first thing I
worry about is you know Ukraine is kind
of depleted on their own military Pat
you know how do we feel when Russians
capture a Ukrainian unit and they get a
hold a couple of these now they got our
stuff and they can take it apart and
figure it out and you know copy it
that's always been part of war is
capture the other guy's crap and then
reverse engineer it or find out the
secrets that are inside as weapons
and I I think that the U.S on a world
stage right now you know is is a little
bit depleted now this is a defense
contractor saying it's going to take me
five years to I mean two years to
rebuild all those missiles and can I uh
can I send you an invoice today
it's also people sit there and go uh Hey
buy some Raytheon today well by the way
I'm sure those guys are loving what's
going on of course I'm sure they're
saying send more stuff to you send more
stuff to Ukraine because I got to
replace it for you and there's only five
of us yeah we're competing against the
defense contractors Believe It or Not
Lobby for a thing called war games where
you see the war games going on yeah they
do that in South Korea yeah they they
Lobby for the use of it
um and now obviously they don't use
nukes in war games but they use up a lot
of stuff they do simulations they do a
lot of things and then you need
replacement parts you need all the stuff
and it's another invoice to the defense
contractors but to your core Point yeah
I do think we're getting getting
slightly weakened on an international
stage in terms of actual
um Readiness of having the tools that we
need to fight and then we're also I
think getting weak because you know
we could do five podcasts in a row on
the flip-flops on Ukraine we're just
gonna let it's not our business it's
from it's not our business to here's
billions of dollars worth of stuff to
fight remember where this started uh
We're not gonna get involved in a proxy
war and be shipping our stuff over there
uh okay give them some tanks remember
this yeah it's been a slippery slope and
so we I don't think our position looks
very strong we change every three weeks
and I I think we're weaker on a world
stage I think the the best what's the uh
saying in football what are Ravens won
the Super Bowl offense is defense yeah
the best offense is a great deal yeah
that's what Ronald Reagan said if we
have a great military defense guess what
no one is doing anything now you know
how you know you create fun account like
you're like hey you know I have a
savings your investment you're this and
you create a what you create a sports
account or whatever you want to call it
right yeah you know what the fun account
Splurge account is to me here's the
weapons that we can give to others for
support but we will never touch what we
need to be protected so this is when we
need to be protected guess what yeah the
javelin we're hitting shortage we can
only give you 700 we can't give you the
whole 8 600. yeah those are the things
as long as we're playing within those
parameters then we can support those
that have generally been a good Ally to
us I'll just say this uh I think we have
every right to question the amount of
money that is going to Ukraine okay what
I think is unquestionable is standing up
to authoritarian regimes who are
invading Sovereign Nations I mean if you
look at this this this article right
Ukraine is the West War now it's not
just the US it is the entire you know
Western World Western Civilization the
EU NATO okay but here it is the Western
alliances geopolitical adversaries are
calculating whether the U.S and its
allies have the stamp stamina and the
cohesion to defend here it is the
rules-based international order that has
benefited the West for decades the
future of Taiwan of Taiwan and South
China Sea is closely linked to the West
record
in Ukraine so there's precedent there's
rules there's a rules-based
international order like we've said
before you can't just go invade a
country what precedent does that does
that establish so next thing you know he
invades Ukraine and then then it's what
he takes over Kiev he owns Ukraine now
and then it's Poland and then what
happens so at some point the only thing
that strong men
respond to is the word no you can't do
[__] like this Putin we have every right
to question how much money we're
spending totally right
but to stand you know there's hard power
and there's soft power right now we need
to be projecting both hard power is
actually fighting in Wars but soft power
is also standing for democracy no nobody
like for example what FDR did to get a
third term you know and what Putin's
doing to get a third term and what he
was doing to uh what was his name is
Vivaldi or uh navalny you know what was
his uh in Russia the competitor of
Alexia navalny where the airport was on
the flight he was poison we're not
supportive of that at all whatsoever no
one is saying that all I'm saying is you
can't control what your enemy does you
try to America has tried for many many
years and some of them they've been able
to control this is not an enemy you can
control we have to Pivot on our own
knowing
discretionary that we can afford after
all our expenses are covered fine but
our expenses are not covered our defense
is not covered and we're trying to solve
everyone's problems yeah and responding
way too much money with this so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]